[Musik]
ein auto als waffe
kaum ein angriff ist derart verheerend
und gleichzeitig so leicht zu begehen
wie mit dem transportmittel nummer eins
in deutschland erschreckend wie oft das
auch hierzulande schon passiert ist die
aktuellsten beispiele eine chronik des
paares
[Musik]
volkmarsen februar 2020 am rosenmontag
steuert einem 29 jahre alter deutscher
sein auto absichtlich in die menge in
der nordhessischen stadt werden dutzende
menschen verletzt darunter 20 kinder
einen politischen hintergrund schließen
die ermittler aus wegen versuchten
mordes und gefährlicher körperverletzung
kommt der täter in untersuchungshaft
am 16 dezember 2021 wird der täter zu
einer lebenslangen freiheitsstrafe
verurteilt bottrop januar 2009 10 wenige
minuten nach dem jahreswechsel fährt ein
autofahrer im ruhrgebiet in eine
menschenmenge es gibt vier verletzte
zwei weitere versuche in bottrop und
essen passanten anzufahren schlagen
vielen der 50 jahre alte täter wird in
die geschlossene psychiatrie eingewiesen
münster april 2001 ein mann rast mit
einem campingbus in eine gruppe von
menschen vor einer beliebten gaststätte
dann erschießt er sich fünf menschen
sterben mehr als 20 werden verletzt die
ermittler gehen davon aus dass der täter
psychisch kranker heidelberg februar
2007 am rande der altstadt fährt ein 35
jähriger seinen mietwagen in eine
menschengruppe auf dem gehweg ein 73
jahre alter mann steht der täter gilt
als schuldunfähig die richter weisen um
dauerhaft in die psychiatrie
berlin juli 2006 während der fußball wm
fährt ein 33 jähriger mit seinem
kleinwagen absichtlich in die
menschenmenge auf der fanmeile am
brandenburger tor rund 20 menschen
werden der amokfahrer kommt in eine
psychiatrische
amok mit dem auto einfach gas geben und
wehrlosen menschen kein verbrechen ist
so leicht zu begehen
so schwer zu verändern